about four years ago one of the world's
most beautiful cover girls burst on the
screen when she was chased by a gang of
motorcycle riders she's here tonight
accompanied by a talented gentleman who
arrived on a bike they're both beautiful
people Lauren Hutton and Danny Thomas
may the best achievements and
documentary films there are two orbs a
documentary film by the way is a film of
fact as opposed to fiction such as the
introduction ski nose just gave me I did
not arrive by Honda
I came by camel anyway was happy with
you carry on voice for feature-length
documentaries the nominees are Antonia
a portrait of the woman Judy Collins and
Jill got Miller producers the challenge
a tribute to modern art Herbert climb
tradition the 81st blow
joke well Eric David Bergman and Haim
Gouri producers hearts and minds Peter
Davies and Becky Snyder producer the
wild in the brave Natalie R Jones and
Eugene s Jones producers and the winner
is the winner is hearts and minds
thank you so much it's ironic of course
to get a prize for a war movie wealthy
suffering in Vietnam continues but I
feel very lucky that we have it even
luckier in our colleagues in filming
dick Pierce Tom Cohen and Brendan Jones
and in editing Lindsey klingmann and
Susan Martin who deserve the award
equally with Burt and me mostly though I
have been blessed not just lucky with
the support and inspiration of my wife
Johanna and with the patience of our
sons who I hope will grow up in a
country and atmosphere somewhat
different from the one we had to portray
in hearts and minds and who I hope will
go to bed now thank you
first of all I would like to say a
special thank you to my late brother
Stanley whose support and love and
encouragement allowed us to make this
film and all of the funds the DBS made
it is ironic that we are here at a time
just before Vietnam is about to be
liberated I will now read a short wire
that I have been asked to read by the
Vietnamese people it is sent by
ambassador din Botti who is the chief of
the provisional Revolutionary Government
delegation to Paris the Paris political
talks it says please transmit to all our
friends in America our recognition of
all that they have done on behalf of
peace and for the application of the
Paris Accords on Vietnam these actions
serve the legitimate interest of the
American people and the Vietnamese
people greetings of friendship to all
the American people thank you very much
and for the best short documentary film
the nominees are city out of wilderness
Francis Thompson for yourself don't
Robin Lehman producing Exploratorium on
Boston tradition John Muir's High Sierra
DeWitt Jones and Leslie Foster producers
naked yoga
Ronald s Cass and Mervyn Lloyd producers
and the winner is anteaters I get to do
this surface and the winner is and the
winner is hmm don't
thank you very much
this is deeply appreciated I think also
because if the film says anything it
says let's save a little bit of nature
for children and ancestors to come thank
you